so i made a few videos about weathery
things like rainbows and clouds and
things but one thing we haven't really
talked about which clearly has a lot of
physics behind it is thunderstorms
lightning and thunder and so i thought
i'd talk a little bit about that
professor you're the 60 symbols we're
the man
i need a map to stand in front of don't
really the forecast for this particular
video is it's quite complicated so
usually when i kind of think it'd be
nice to do a video about something i
kind of you know i know a bit about it
and then i'll go and read up a bit more
about it this is one of those cases
where you keep coming across where
things where people say and we really
don't know x or we can't understand why
it turns out even today there are
significant gaps in our knowledge about
how thunderstorms work i mean we'll talk
a little bit about what we don't know
but there are some bits that we do know
so i'll sort of sketch out what we do
know probably not all of it but some of
the bits and pieces of the what the
underlying physics is so let's start
with with this find my lectures on
physics classic textbook and in fact it
was my first interest in in the physics
of thunderstorms actually came from
reading this many many years ago where
did you get this book ah so this was a
prize there are three of them yeah there
are three volumes and in volume one you
can see where i got it from i could have
put them in different books but i
decided to get one expensive book to
find my lecture notes and actually so
one's a prize for physics and the other
is a prize for maths so each of which
sort of came with a cheap book and i
decided to combine them to buy something
a bit more expensive one of the long
sections of the books is about
electromagnetism electricity and
magnetism and there's a sort of section
within that where feynman talks about
thunderstorms and which is why i sort of
first got interested in thunderstorms
it's sort of a good place to start
although so bear in mind this was the
1960s when this was written and there
are various entertaining bits about
there which kind of reveal the level of
ignorance at the time which actually had
for in large part hasn't been fixed
since so let me read just this bit of
the book so it's all about electric
charges because we're going to be
talking about electrostatics so he talks
about this and he says that the top of
the thunderstorm has a positive charge
and the bottom a negative one except for
a small local region of positive charge
at the bottom of the cloud which has
caused everyone a lot of worry no one
seems to know why it's there how it is
important whether it's a secondary
effect of the positive rain coming down
or whether it is an essential part of
the machinery things will be much
simpler if it weren't there so
it's kind of a slightly complicated
picture but the basics are kind of
fairly straightforward which is that a
lightning strike is really just an
electric discharge to get that you need
a big voltage difference which
essentially means you need a bunch of
positive charges here and a bunch of
negative charges here
and then the things sort of fairly
catastrophically re-equalize and the
charges all balance out by a spark of
electricity essentially a current flying
from one to the other to make the thing
all equalize out and indeed as firemen
just said in that little bit of this
book you've got this picture where
you've got the classic kind of anvil
shaped thunder cloud where positive
charges
end up at the top and negative charges
end up at the bottom and then there's
this inconvenient little bit of positive
charge at the bottom so we have to come
up with a mechanism for separating out
the charge and it turns out that the
mechanism that thunderclouds use is
actually one that we use in the lab as
well and so we can kind of introduce it
by talking about how we create charge
separation in the lab and the sort of
the classic way of doing that is a thing
called a van de graaff generator
[Music]
a device that a guy called van de graaff
came up with in the 1930s actually it
was more recent than i thought it was
1930s he was interested in smashing
things together at very high energy and
so i wanted to accelerate particles and
so the way he did that if it's a charged
particle if you've got a big voltage
then you can accelerate the charged
particle um and use it for
smashing into nuclei smashing into atoms
and so on
so he was really interested in ways of
accelerating particles we now have
different ways of doing that so the van
de graaff generator has really kind of
become a
almost a teaching device these days
rather than something which is used in
cutting-edge physics but most physics
labs around the world will have a
van de graaff generator in it somewhere
so there was a time when this was like a
important piece of actual science kit it
really was in the 1930s it was the
state-of-the-art way of producing large
voltages to allow you to accelerate
things and they made some huge van de
graaff generators there are some truly
spectacular examples one thing that
people most people know about physics is
about static electricity that if you rub
two materials together you can actually
create a static charge and it's the way
you know if you've got a balloon and you
rub it against your jumper you can make
the balloon stick to the ceiling and all
those kinds of things static electricity
the van de graaff generator works from
exactly this phenomenon it's more
technical name is it's called the
triboelectric effect but it's basically
static electricity so if you have a van
de graaff generator
what it's inside look like is you've got
just basically a belt
continually traveling around and this
belt is rubbing against this upper
roller
and creating static electricity
and that basically separates charge out
so you've got the thing going around
you end up charging the belt
negatively and then the
the roller positively the belt then
carries on and carries a negative charge
away which leaves the positive charge
here
then
you can see there's this little kind of
comb
here
and the reason why you've got these sort
of very fine teeth here is that the
interaction of the positive charges here
and these very fine teeth creates a very
strong electric field
in this this region
so very strong kind of electric forces
just due to the very point-like nature
of this this comb which actually is
sufficiently strong to make the air
break down
and so that current can start to flow so
they're kind of mini sparks it's kind of
a current flows and so this positive
charge can then redistribute itself
around the outside
of the van de graaff generator
and because you've got this thing
continuously running this process just
goes on and on and on so you add more
and more positive charge to the outside
um and the negative gets carried away
down to earth and you can use you know
use that to
charge negatively as separate a separate
conductor over here the only tricky bit
about that is and the bit i kind of
skated over in there is i said oh it's
all just static electricity
it turns out the process by which
rubbing two things together in this case
this bolt and roller lead to charge
separation is really poorly understood
when you rub two things together
depending on which materials you pick
one of them will charge positively and
the other will charge negatively
and so and there are kind of rules as to
which materials you should pick to
charge positively and negatively
one of the perversities of this and one
of the reasons why we don't understand
it as well as we'd like to is that
actually it turns out we think you know
you say you produce a set of rules that
says rub these two together and i should
get this
and once in a while you get the opposite
of what you're expecting which means
that actually we don't understand things
quite as well as we thought we did one
of the classic things that people use to
produce electricity in this way actually
is amber turns out if you rub amber with
the then that's a very good way of
producing static electricity this was
known back in ancient times because
actually the word electron is actually
the greek word for amber so actually the
whole history of electricity and our
understanding of things like electrons
goes back to the ancient greeks and
doing these kind of static electricity
experiments professor what is it about
the rubbing that creates the charge
separation so that's the bit that's
really not on us firstly it's not really
friction so you think i'm rubbing two
things together i'm creating friction
the important part of that process of
rubbing the two things together is
effectively what you're doing is
very very many times per second bringing
two surfaces together and pulling them
apart again
so actually that process of rubbing
things together is just a very effective
way of bringing surfaces together and
pulling them apart and it's that process
of bringing things together and pulling
them apart that produces this static
electricity effect so probably what
happens is there's a process when you
bring two different materials together
it's a process called adhesion which is
that they start trying to stick together
and again there are lots of ways that
adhesion can happen it can happen
through chemical bonds starting to
happen between two different materials
it can happen just because the surface
is kind of locked together and so what
happens is you put bring these two
surfaces together they start to stick
then when you pull them apart you leave
something behind and so for example you
might imagine you bring these two
surfaces together they start to stick so
an electron maybe becomes shared between
the two surfaces a bit which creates the
beginnings of a chemical bond then you
rip them apart again and maybe
systematically the electrons get left
behind
and so you can see that the net effect
of that is every time you do it
on average you're moving an electron
from here to here leaving this thing
positively charged and this thing
negatively charged and because this
rubbing process is a very effective way
of doing that many many times per second
it that's a then becomes a quite an
efficient way of transferring charge
between the two
but to give you an idea of the level of
uncertainty in this process
there is even still reading some of the
recent scientific literature on this
subject people are still writing papers
about this and there is even still a lot
of debate about whether the thing that
transfers from one to the other is
always an electron or actually sometimes
whether it's a positively charged so you
can think if you've got a an atom you
can think of it as an electron and the
kind of positively charged remnants
which might have other electrons still
around it but i think we'll deny and
positively charged thing people are
still arguing about whether this process
transfers ions across or whether it
transfers electrons across which kind of
gives you an indication of the
fundamental lack of understanding what
you have in a thunder cloud is their air
in a thundercloud is very unstable you
get very strong updrafts so you have air
being kind of sucked up to the tops of
these things the reason why they have
this characteristic shape to them is the
air gets kind of sucked up and then
spreads out as it reaches the top
within these clouds they're typically
quite a long way below freezing so you
have ice and in fact the ice comes in
two solder flavors there are little ice
crystals
and there are big hail wet hail things
which if they have a technical name
they're called grapple the group are
these kind of big wet hail stones and
you've got these little ice crystals
because the little ice crystals are much
lighter the updrafts just lift them up
whereas the grapple because it's heavier
is is able to resist that upward force
and actually just falls under gravity so
you've got this little ice crystals
going up and there's wet hailstones
falling down and of course they collide
with one another that transfers positive
charge from the hailstones to the ice
crystals the little ice crystals then
continue to rise up taking the positive
charge with them and end up charging the
top of that cloud with a positive charge
the hailstones continue to fall taking
the negative charge down with them and
creating the negative charge at the
bottom so that's how you get this charge
separation and because there are an
awful lot of these little collisions
going on all the time although each one
only transfers a tiny amount of charge
just as with the van de graaff generator
the net effect of all those collisions
going on is to transfer a huge amount of
charge so you can create an enormous
potential difference between the top of
the cloud and the bottom of the cloud
enough to actually create sparks so are
you saying most lightning is just
transferring from one side of the cloud
to the other because when i think of
lightning i think of electricity going
from a cloud down to the ground so
that's when life gets really complicated
so there's a potential difference
between the bottom of the cloud now
which is quite strongly negatively
charged and the ground which actually is
positively charged
so there are
positively charged
that's again another very good question
and it's again
something which is a slightly open
question as to whether it is if you go
away from a cloud and ask whether you
know whether the ground is positive
relative to the air higher up it turns
out that it is
and so something again is continually
charging the earth up or removing charge
from the earth again and it's probably
again some quite subtle static
electricity effect are you telling me
that the earth is positively charged it
is there's a huge voltage between the
earth and the top of your head yeah
it turns out
i also had no idea that charging clouds
was caused by eyes smashing into each
other
and i think the other thing to emphasize
is that's the best theory and people
have done lab experiments to show that
indeed you can if you crash these little
ice crystals it's quite a hard thing to
do in the lab but if you crash little
ice crystals into these bigger wet
hailstones you do create charge transfer
so we know the effect the phenomenon
does work
whether it's really what's driving
everything that's going on in
thunderstorms isn't clear
and then the whole question about well
how does the thing discharge and there's
a whole kind of phenomenology of what
goes on you can have lightning between
one cloud and another lightning within a
cloud lightning from from cloud to
ground sometimes lightning goes
downwards sometimes it's thing called
the leader when it's going downwards
sometimes you see the flash going back
upwards with high speed photography so
there's a very complicated a lot of
physics that's going on but the
underlying mechanism behind it is this
charge separation and almost certainly
the underlying
mechanism between that charge separation
is this triboelectric effect which
causes these enormous static charges
within clouds
in terms of what about what triggers the
lightning like you've got these huge
charges building up is there like a
critical mass or a magic number or like
what makes the lightning thing all right
enough's enough i'm i'm doing it and
again it's complicated and it looks like
the story is not that well understood if
you do the the kind of the naive
calculation you find that actually there
isn't enough voltage there to trigger
the lightning strike
so then the question is well what is it
we see lightning strikes and so there
are some pretty extreme theories which
are actually quite credible like it
could be that a high-energy cosmic ray
from space
has crashed into the cloud created a
kind of a share of charge
and that's enough to kind of create the
ionization which just kicks the thing
off but what it is exactly really again
really isn't that well understood why it
is that lightning triggers at one moment
and not another moment that's crazy
typical astronomer
it's all down to astronomy really isn't
it yeah
i've never even heard that theory that's
amazing you know that yeah
but that is that one of the fringe
theories i don't think so i that's the
trouble i've been really struggling to
find you know usually this one narrative
that i can use for a video like this
that says most people think it's this
way right it really is still quite
complicated and messy and although we
sort of understand
quite a lot of the underlying basic
physics how it all gets put together in
detail and what some what all the
elements are still isn't clear wikipedia
hasn't got the answer even wikipedia
doesn't have the answer
[Music]
you